en su primera intervención bennett hizo
un llamado a la unidad y la
reconciliación nacional pero como es
recibido el hecho de que un
ultranacionalista haga esta petición en
el país
es difícil determinarlo porque es muy
prematuro todavía lo que parece es que
casi cualquier cosa que hubiera sacado a
netanyahu para el bloque del cambio este
este nuevo a esta nueva coalición
liderada por bennett y el lápiz que se
llama en el bloque del cambio casi
cualquier cosa que hubieran hecho
hubiera sido bienvenida porque el
espíritu nacional desde hace mucho
tiempo por lo menos de gran parte de la
población israelí es que querían que
fuera desalojada ya la residencia del
primer ministro por netanyahu y pedían
cambio y sin embargo la mayoría por él
por la que ganó a este gobierno del
cambio fue muy muy muy raspadita en
hasta el último minuto no se supo si iba
a suceder o no iba a suceder y que
bennett a pelé a la unidad nacional y en
la restauración es realmente algo que
parece ser que es el gran sentir de los
israelíes
hay mucho conflicto social el partido
en la que en ese del parlamento está
dividido pero es un fiel reflejo de la
sociedad israelí que está dividida
también dividida y bastante furiosa como
se vio hoy antes de la votación antes
del voto de confianza del nuevo gobierno
que hubo
mientras benítez intentaba dar su
discurso fue interrumpido en múltiples
ocasiones precisamente por esta falta de
coordinación